- [Voiceover] What I
hope to do in this video
is leverage some of our
experience and knowledge
from the quadratic world
to factor, and rewrite,
and re-express expressions
that are higher degree,
higher degree polynomials.
So what am I talking about?
So let's say that I have the expression
a to the sixth power,
plus 2a to the third power b squared,
plus b to the fourth,
and I want to factor this.
I want to write this as a
product of two expressions.
How do I do that?
And at first, it might
seem a little intimidating.
I have a to the sixth power!
This is a sixth degree term,
you have b to the fourth power,
how do I handle it?
But a clue, you might say,
"Well, this is kind of
"looking like when I took a square of
"a expression with two variables."
So let's just take a little
bit of a detour here.
If I took x plus y, squared,
what is this going to be equal to?
Well, this is x plus y, times x plus y,
which is, of course, going to be equal to,
x times x is x squared,
then you have x times y is xy,
but then you have y times x as well,
so you have 2xy's, and this is all review.
If this isn't review, I
encourage you to watch
the videos on multiplying expressions,
and then, or multiplying
binomials, I guess you could say,
and then you finally have y times y,
so you'd have plus y squared.
So when you write it like this,
you see well it looks like
there might be a parallel.
This a to the sixth term looks like it
might parallel to this x squared term,
and this b to the fourth
looks like it might
parallel to this, 'cause notice,
if I have something squared here,
and then I have that
something in this middle term,
and I have something squared here,
and I have that something
in that middle term,
and then I have a two,
well then, that means that
this thing is a perfect square.
It's x plus y, squared,
and we do have that.
Notice, a to the sixth,
that's the same thing as
a to the third, squared,
and then we have an a to the third
right here, sitting in this middle term.
So let me write that.
We have that a to the third there,
and of course we have this plus two there,
and then b to the fourth,
well, that's the same thing
as b squared, squared,
and of course, we also have a b squared
in this middle term.
So when you write it this way,
it has the exact same pattern
as we had right over here.
This thing is nothing but,
let me write it this way,
as a to the third, let
me do it in those colors,
as a to the third, plus b squared,
and then that whole quantity squared,
and you can see, look, if
we were to multiply it out,
and actually, let me just do it,
I'll do it all in white,
so it makes sense to you,
or, so actually, it might
make a little less sense,
'cause I'm not gonna take--
Actually, let me switch colors,
so it's gonna be a to the third,
plus b squared,
times a to the third, plus b squared.
Well, a to the third times a to the third
is a to the sixth.
a to the third plus b
squared, that's gonna be
a to the third, b squared,
and then you're gonna have b
squared times a to the third,
well that's just another
a to the third, b squared,
so actually, let's just write this as
2a to the third,
b squared,
and then finally, b
squared times b squared
is going to be b to the fourth power.
So once again, if you
see something like this,
you're like, okay, it seems daunting,
but it seems close to a
pattern that I've seen
when I've been dealing with quadratics.
This looks close to a
perfect square quadratic,
and if you actually write this out,
it's actually a pretty big hit,
you see, well look, if
x is a to the third,
and y is b squared, then these
are the exact same thing.
So this is a factored out version of it.
Let's do another one of these.
So let's say, let me draw
a little dotted line here,
and let's say that we have
an eighth degree polynomial.
We have x to the eighth,
minus 12x to the fourth, minus two,
and we want to complete the square here,
and you're probably used
to completing the square
with second degree
polynomials, or quadratics,
and all of a sudden you
have an eighth degree,
but there's no reason why
you can't do that here,
'cause we could say this is
going to be the same thing as
x to the eighth, minus
12x to the fourth power.
Whoops, my primitive brain
wrote x squared there.
x to the eighth, minus 12x to the fourth,
and let me create some space
to add and subtract something,
and then let me put
the minus two out here,
and we just have to realize that, look,
for it to be a perfect square,
that this is x to the fourth,
squared right over here.
We have an x to the fourth here,
and so, just like we
would complete the square
if we were doing it with a
second degree polynomial,
or quadratic, you would take
half the coefficient here,
which is six, and then we
would want to add that,
so we would want to add,
well, we wouldn't add
half that coefficient,
we would add the square
of half that coefficient.
This is just how you complete the square,
if this was an x squared,
and this was just an x,
and the key here is just realize
that x to the eighth, is
x to the fourth, squared.
When you did it with quadratics,
you just had an x here, and
you just had the x squared.
Now you have an x to the fourth here,
and you have x to the fourth squared,
which is x to the eighth.
But you take half of this coefficient,
which is six.
You could do it as negative six,
since you have this out here,
but then you square it, and you get 36.
But you can't just add 36
willy, nilly to an expression.
That changes its value.
In order to not change its value,
you also need to subtract 36.
But the whole point of doing it is,
this part of it now is a perfect square.
It's a perfect square
eighth degree polynomial.
So this is going to be the same thing as
x to the fourth,
minus, let me write it this way,
minus six, squared.
Maybe I should have written this in blue.
The colors are the hard part.
x to the fourth, minus six,
and then the whole thing squared,
and then, of course, I have to worry about
these two characters out here.
If I subtract 36 and then subtract two,
well, that's the same
thing as subtracting 38.
So just like that, this is just like
completing the square with
a second degree polynomial,
but I just did it with an
eighth degree polynomial.
Let's do one more,
just to really exercise this muscle.
This, in some ways, isn't a new skill.
This is just looking at an old skill,
and applying it to slightly hairier,
slightly more complex things,
or maybe realizing that they
aren't that more complex.
So let's say that we had
25x to the sixth,
minus 16y squared.
So let's do this at the top.
What are other ways we can write this?
Can we factor things?
What are other ways could we write it?
Well, one way that we could write it,
we could say that, look,
25 is five squared,
and x to the sixth is x
to the third, squared,
so we could rewrite
this right over here as
five squared, times
x to the third, squared,
and then we have minus,
16 is four squared.
Let me do this in this color.
16 is four squared, y squared,
so we could write it like this if we like.
But we could also write it,
we have five to the second power,
we have x to the third,
to the second power.
Well we could use our exponent properties,
say, well this is going
to be the same thing as
5x to the third, to the second power.
If I have a product of two things,
and I raise it to the power,
that's the same thing as
taking the product of each of them,
raised to the power,
or, if I take the product and
then raise it to the power,
that's the same thing as
raising them each to the power first,
and then taking the product.
It's one of our exponent properties.
Now we could do the same thing
for the second term.
Four squared times y
squared is the same thing as
4y, squared,
and when you write it like this,
and this is another legitimate way
to rewrite this higher degree expression,
you now see that this is
a difference of squares,
and if it's a difference of squares,
we can rewrite it as,
let me do it like this.
We can rewrite it as
5x to the third
plus 4y,
times 5x to the third
minus 4y.
Once again, this comes straight out of
when you first learned
a squared, minus b squared is equal to
a plus b, times a minus b.
In this case, a is 5x to the third power,
and b is 4y,
and you see that right over here.
So once again, whole point here is
just apply some of our quadratic toolkit,
but applying it to higher
degree polynomials,
and seeing that it's really,
on some levels, the same thing.